witaj z powrotem w kursie „Zrozumieć kwantową informację i obliczenia" – nazywam się John Watrous i jestem dyrektorem technicznym ds. edukacji
w IBM Quantum. To dziewiąta lekcja serii i pierwsza lekcja trzeciej jednostki, która dotyczy ogólnego
sformułowania informacji kwantowej. Do tej pory korzystaliśmy z uproszczonego sformułowania
informacji kwantowej, w którym stany kwantowe są reprezentowane przez zespolone wektory o euklidesowej normie równej
jeden. W przeciwieństwie do tego, w ogólnym sformułowaniu informacji kwantowej stany kwantowe są reprezentowane przez
macierze pewnego rodzaju, zwane macierzami gęstości. Ta pierwsza lekcja jednostki skupia się konkretnie na macierzach gęstości
i dowiemy się, czym są i jak działają w miarę postępu lekcji. Macierze gęstości są niezwykle
użyteczne i oferują różne zalety, które omówimy. Pozwalają nam reprezentować
szerszą klasę stanów niż wektory stanu kwantowego, w tym stany układów, na które wpłynął szum, jak również losowe
wybory stanów kwantowych. Przyjrzymy się też sferze Blocha, która daje nam bardzo ładny
i prosty geometryczny sposób myślenia o stanach qubit i zobaczymy, jak łączy się ona z macierzami gęstości w
dość zadziwiający sposób za pośrednictwem macierzy Pauliego. Na koniec omówimy macierze gęstości w kontekście wielu
układów, a w szczególności zobaczymy, jak pozwalają nam opisywać stany kwantowe układów postrzeganych w izolacji, nawet gdy
są skorelowane z innymi układami, a to obejmuje możliwość splątania z innymi układami. To ważna rzecz
do zrobienia i nie jest łatwa w uproszczonym sformułowaniu informacji kwantowej. Oto przegląd
lekcji. Zaczniemy od podstaw macierzy gęstości, w tym odpowiednich definicji i kilku przykładów, a
także omówimy ich związek z wektorami stanu kwantowego. Następnie porozmawiamy o kombinacjach wypukłych macierzy gęstości, czyli
innymi słowy o tym, co się dzieje, gdy bierzemy ważone średnie macierzy gęstości. Zaczniemy od konkretnego
przykładu tak zwanego stanu całkowicie mieszanego. Zobaczymy, jak klasyczne stany probabilistyczne można postrzegać jako
szczególne przypadki macierzy gęstości i omówimy, jak twierdzenie spektralne z algebry liniowej wchodzi w grę w
tym kontekście. Trzecia część lekcji dotyczy sfery Blocha, która zapewnia geometryczny sposób oglądania stanów
pojedynczych qubit, jak wspomniałem na początku lekcji. W czwartej części lekcji porozmawiamy o tym, jak macierze gęstości działają dla wielu
układów. Omówimy stany produktowe i skorelowane stany różnych rodzajów, w tym stany splątane, jak również
pojęcie stanu zredukowanego, który jest opisem gęstościowym stanu izolowanej części złożonego układu
obliczanym za pomocą operacji zwanej śladem częściowym. Zanim przejdziemy do technicznej treści lekcji,
warto poświęcić chwilę, by uzasadnić stosowanie macierzy gęstości. W uproszczonym
sformułowaniu informacji kwantowej, które nie obejmuje macierzy gęstości, możemy opisywać algorytmy kwantowe, takie jak
algorytm faktoryzacji Shora, bez żadnych trudności. Dlaczego więc mamy zawracać sobie głowę macierzami gęstości
lub tym ogólnym sformułowaniem informacji kwantowej w ogóle? Cóż, jest wiele powodów. Po pierwsze, macierze gęstości
reprezentują szerszą klasę stanów kwantowych niż wektory stanu kwantowego, w tym stany kwantowe, w których mamy niepewność lub
losowość. Jest to ważne, gdy chcemy modelować wpływ szumu na obliczenia kwantowe,
na przykład. Po drugie, używając macierzy gęstości, możemy opisywać stany kwantowe izolowanych części złożonych układów, takie
jak stany układów, które są splątane z innymi układami, które być może chwilowo wybieramy ignorować, jak wspomniałem na początku
lekcji. Nie jest to łatwe ani naturalne w uproszczonym sformułowaniu informacji
kwantowej. Trzecim powodem jest to, że gdy używamy macierzy gęstości, informacja klasyczna faktycznie wyłania się jako
szczególny przypadek. Zamiast mieć to, co jest zasadniczo analogią między stanami probabilistycznymi i operacjami
z jednej strony a wektorami stanu kwantowego i operacjami unitarnymi z drugiej, mamy informację kwantową i klasyczną
opisywaną razem w ramach jednego formalnego matematycznie, co jest niemal niezbędne do matematycznego studium
informacji kwantowej. Jeśli więc poważnie podchodzisz do zrozumienia informacji kwantowej na poziomie matematycznym, zdecydowanie
zaleca się poznanie macierzy gęstości. Zacznijmy od definicji macierzy
gęstości. Na potrzeby definicji załóżmy, że X jest układem, a sigma jest jego klasycznym zbiorem stanów i przypomnij, że
gdy używamy tej terminologii, zakładamy, że Sigma jest skończony i niepusty, i jak zawsze możemy wybrać
inne nazwy, jeśli chcemy. Macierz gęstości opisująca stan układu X jest macierzą o zespolonych
wpisach, której wiersze i kolumny są przypisane do jego klasycznego zbioru stanów – i żeby być precyzyjnym,
jest to ta sama korespondencja dla wierszy i kolumn jednocześnie. Oznacza to, że macierze
gęstości są zawsze macierzami kwadratowymi, a oprócz bycia kwadratowymi istnieją kilka warunków, które muszą być
spełnione – przejdziemy do nich wkrótce. Zazwyczaj do nazywania macierzy gęstości używa się pewnych małych greckich liter,
rho jest często pierwszym wyborem, a inne powszechne wybory obejmują małe sigma i tau, które są pokazane na
ekranie. To tylko konwencja, ale jak zwykle tego rodzaju konwencje są pomocne, bo sprawiają, że rzeczy są bardziej
rozpoznawalne. A teraz porozmawiajmy o warunkach lub wymaganiach, które macierze gęstości muszą spełniać, by być
poprawnymi macierzami gęstości. Jest ich dwa, a co zrobię, to najpierw po prostu je wymienię
i następnie omówię szczegółowo, co oznaczają. Pierwszym warunkiem jest to, że macierze
gęstości muszą mieć ślad jednostkowy, innymi słowy ślad równy jeden. Drugim warunkiem jest to, że
macierze gęstości muszą być dodatnio półokreślone, a w obu przypadkach mamy zwięzłe symboliczne sposoby wyrażania
tych dwóch warunków, które są widoczne na ekranie. Omówię teraz te dwa warunki bardziej szczegółowo.
Pierwszy warunek odnosi się do śladu, który jest bardzo ważną funkcją zdefiniowaną dla wszystkich macierzy kwadratowych
i jest po prostu sumą elementów przekątniowych. Oto równanie, które to wyraża
wprost. Można powiedzieć wiele o śladzie i dlaczego jest ważny, ale na razie zauważmy tylko
jedną bardzo podstawową właściwość: jest on funkcją liniową. Inne właściwości śladu będą pojawiać się i będziemy je omawiać, gdy
zajdzie potrzeba. Ale skupiając się na macierzach gęstości, przejdźmy do drugiego wymagania, a mianowicie tego, że
macierze gęstości są dodatnio półokreślone. Jest to również ważne pojęcie pojawiające się w wielu kontekstach w
WEBVTT
fizyce, chemii, optymalizacji, uczeniu maszynowym i innych dziedzinach, i można je wyrazić na kilka różnych, ale
równoważnych sposobów. Jednym ze sposobów wyrażenia tego jest stwierdzenie, że macierz rho jest dodatnio półokreślona, jeśli istnieje macierz M
taka, że rho jest równe M dagger razy M, i okazuje się, że nie ma znaczenia, czy żądamy, by M sama była
macierzą kwadratową, czy rezygnujemy z tego ograniczenia. Innym sposobem wyrażenia tego, co oznacza, że macierz rho jest dodatnio
półokreślona, jest stwierdzenie, że rho jest hermitowska, co oznacza, że jest równa swojej sprzężonej transpozycji, i że wszystkie
jej wartości własne są nieujemnymi liczbami rzeczywistymi. Ogólnie rzecz biorąc, macierze hermitowskie mogą
mieć tylko rzeczywiste wartości własne, ale mogą być ujemne. Jeśli jednak dodamy dodatkowe ograniczenie, że żadna
z wartości własnych nie może być ujemna, otrzymamy macierze dodatnio półokreślone. Przy okazji, jeśli masz daną
macierz i chcesz wiedzieć, czy jest dodatnio półokreślona, możesz to sprawdzić za pomocą tej charakteryzacji. Całkiem łatwo
sprawdzić, czy macierz jest hermitowska – to można ocenić wzrokowo. Trudniej jest obliczyć
wartości własne, ale to też nie jest zbyt trudne przy użyciu komputera, bo istnieją bardzo wydajne algorytmy do tego
celu. Ostatnia charakteryzacja, którą wspomnę, choć jest ich więcej, to ta: dla każdego wektora kolumnowego s mającego
tyle wpisów, ile wynosi liczba wierszy i kolumn rho, nierówność pokazana na
ekranie jest prawdziwa. Innymi słowy, bra s razy rho razy ket s musi być nieujemną liczbą
rzeczywistą. Nie jest oczywiste, że te charakteryzacje są wszystkie równoważne, ale są, i wyraźnie zaznaczam, że
notacja, której powszechnie używamy, by wskazać, że macierz rho jest dodatnio półokreślona, wygląda jak rho jest większe
lub równe zero, ale to tylko notacja skrótowa i nie oznacza dosłownie, że rho jest większe lub równe
zero. Rho jest macierzą, więc to nie miałoby sensu. Nie oznacza to też,
że każdy z wpisów rho jest większy lub równy zero. W szczególności istnieją macierze
dodatnio półokreślone, których wpisy nie są wszystkie nieujemne, i istnieją macierze, których wpisy są wszystkie
nieujemne, ale nie są one dodatnio półokreślone. Idea stojąca za notacją jest taka, że macierze dodatnio półokreślone
są jak macierzowe analogi nieujemnych liczb rzeczywistych, ale to tylko notacja i to, co oznacza, to
dokładnie to, co już omówiliśmy. Przyjrzyjmy się teraz kilku przykładom, zaczynając od przykładu
macierzy dodatnio półokreślonej. W rzeczywistości dość łatwo jest losowo wygenerować przykład
macierzy dodatnio półokreślonej, po prostu wybierając macierz M dowolnie, a następnie obliczając M dagger razy
M. Na przykład oto macierz M, która nie jest szczególnie specjalna. W rzeczywistości
wygenerowałem tę macierz losowo, niezależnie wybierając części rzeczywiste i urojone wpisów jako liczby całkowite między minus 9 a plus
9, więc wszelkie wzorce lub struktura tutaj są czysto przypadkowe. Mnożąc
sprzężoną transpozycję M przez M, otrzymujemy tę macierz tutaj, która jest zatem dodatnio
półokreślona. Oczywiście jest ograniczona ilość informacji, jakie możemy uzyskać z losowego przykładu, ale wykazuje on pewne
cechy wspólne macierzom dodatnio półokreślonym bardziej ogólnie. W szczególności zauważysz,
że wpisy przekątniowe, czyli te leżące wzdłuż linii od górnego lewego do dolnego prawego, są wszystkie nieujemnymi liczbami
rzeczywistymi, a ponadto wpisy poza przekątną nie są zbyt duże w porównaniu do odpowiadających im wpisów przekątniowych
– mam tu na myśli ten w tym samym wierszu i ten w tej samej kolumnie co dany wpis poza przekątną.
Jest jednak więcej do powiedzenia, i ważne jest, by rozumieć, że bycie dodatnio półokreślonym to
właściwość macierzy jako całości, a nie tylko warunek na poszczególnych wpisach. To jest przykład macierzy
dodatnio półokreślonej i możesz bardzo łatwo generować inne przykłady przy użyciu podobnej
metodologii. Przyjrzyjmy się teraz kilku przykładom macierzy gęstości, gdzie oprócz warunku dodatniej półokreśloności mamy też, że ślad jest
równy jeden. Oto kilka przykładów macierzy gęstości 2x2. Ślad jest równy
jeden we wszystkich czterech przypadkach, i możemy też zobaczyć, że są to macierze hermitowskie. Używając drugiej charakteryzacji
macierzy dodatnio półokreślonych sprzed chwili, pozostaje jedynie sprawdzić, że wartości własne są wszystkie nieujemne.
Zostawię to tobie do sprawdzenia, jeśli chcesz. Dla macierzy 2x2 obliczenie wartości własnych ręcznie nie jest zbyt trudne,
ale możesz też poprosić komputer, żeby to zrobił. Na przykład możesz użyć funkcji eigvals w pakiecie algebry
liniowej dla Pythona. Możemy też uzyskać macierz gęstości, po prostu biorąc dowolną niezerową
macierz dodatnio półokreśloną i dzieląc przez jej ślad. Na przykład oto macierz gęstości, którą otrzymujemy, dzieląc
przykład, który widzieliśmy chwilę temu, przez jej ślad. Dzielenie przez ślad w ten sposób
zawsze zachowuje właściwość dodatniej półokreśloności i z pewnością otrzymamy macierz o śladzie równym jeden, dzięki temu, że
ślad jest funkcją liniową. To tylko mały zbiór przykładów i zobaczymy więcej w miarę
kontynuacji lekcji. Następnie poświęcimy chwilę na omówienie interpretacji lub
intuicyjnego znaczenia macierzy gęstości. Pierwszą rzeczą, którą należy przyznać, jest to, że może się wydawać trochę niezwykłe,
że reprezentujemy stan układu macierzą, a nie wektorem. W przeciwieństwie do tego w uproszczonym
sformułowaniu informacji kwantowej używamy wektorów do reprezentowania stanów, natomiast macierze – konkretnie macierze unitarne –
reprezentują działania lub operacje. Tak po prostu działa matematyka, i choć zawsze możesz
myśleć o macierzach jako opisujących odwzorowania liniowe, nie kojarzymy zazwyczaj bezpośredniego intuicyjnego
znaczenia z odwzorowaniem liniowym skojarzonym z daną macierzą gęstości. Powiedziawszy to, fakt, że
macierze gęstości są rzeczywiście macierzami, okazuje się być krytycznie ważnym aspektem i zobaczymy
to w miarę kontynuacji. Ale żeby wspomnieć tylko jeden przykład na razie: wartości własne danej macierzy gęstości
okazują się być bardzo ważne, bo opisują, ile losowości lub niepewności jest nieodłącznie związane ze stanem,
który dana macierz gęstości opisuje. Inny sposób myślenia o macierzach gęstości na poziomie intuicyjnym
skupia się na wpisach tych macierzy. Pamiętaj, że wiersze i kolumny macierzy gęstości są przypisane
do klasycznych stanów jakiegokolwiek układu, o którym mówimy. Tak więc dla każdego wpisu mamy jeden
WEBVTT
klasyczny stan odpowiadający wierszowi tego wpisu i jeden klasyczny stan odpowiadający kolumnie tego
wpisu. Dla wpisów przekątniowych te dwa klasyczne stany są tym samym stanem, i dlatego wpisy przekątniowe są
specjalne. Jednym ze sposobów interpretacji wpisów przekątniowych jest to, że są to prawdopodobieństwa, a konkretnie
prawdopodobieństwa, że odpowiadający klasyczny stan pojawiłby się, gdybyśmy przeprowadzili pomiar w standardowej bazie
na układzie, którego stan kwantowy opisujemy. Dla wpisów poza przekątną mamy natomiast jeden klasyczny stan odpowiadający wierszowi
tego wpisu i inny klasyczny stan odpowiadający kolumnie tego wpisu. Bardzo nieformalnie mówiąc,
te wpisy opisują stopień, w jakim te dwa klasyczne stany są w kwantowej superpozycji, jak również
względną fazę między nimi. Może to nabrać więcej sensu w miarę kontynuacji lekcji i przyglądania się
konkretnym przykładom, a szczegóły mogą nie być jasne w tym momencie – ale proszę, nie przejmuj się tym.
To jest zupełnie nieformalne i ma być tylko intuicyjnym pomysłem, który zachowasz z tyłu
głowy. Następnie przyjrzymy się połączeniu między macierzami gęstości a wektorami stanu kwantowego, które są wektorami
kolumnowymi o euklidesowej normie równej jeden. Żeby przypomnieć definicję matematyczną: zakładając, że mamy
wektor stanu kwantowego s reprezentujący stan pewnego konkretnego układu, macierz gęstości reprezentująca ten sam
stan kwantowy jest dana przez ket s razy bra s, jak pokazano tutaj na ekranie. Żeby być precyzyjnym w tej kwestii: indeksy s
odpowiadają w pewien sposób klasycznym stanom jakiegokolwiek układu, o którym mówimy, i to będzie dokładnie ta sama korespondencja, jaką mamy między
wierszami i kolumnami naszej macierzy gęstości a klasycznymi stanami układu. Jeśli wyobrazimy sobie, że istnieje n
klasycznych stanów układu i myślimy o wektorach kolumnowych i wierszowych jako macierzach, to ket s jest macierzą n na 1
a bra s jest macierzą 1 na n. Więc gdy wykonujemy mnożenie, otrzymujemy macierz n na n.
Będzie ona zawsze macierzą dodatnio półokreśloną już ze swojej formy, i będzie też miała ślad równy
jeden dzięki temu, że s jest wektorem jednostkowym, co zobaczymy dokładniej
wkrótce. Stany kwantowe reprezentowane przez macierze gęstości tej formy nazywane są stanami
czystymi. Oto kilka przykładów. Rozważmy najpierw ten stan
tutaj, który jest trochę jak stan plus, z wyjątkiem tego, że wpis odpowiadający klasycznemu stanowi jeden jest
urojony. Jeśli obliczymy sprzężoną transpozycję, dodamy minus, ponieważ sprzężona liczby i wynosi
minus i, a jeśli wykonamy mnożenie, otrzymamy macierz pokazaną tutaj na ekranie. Jest ona hermitowska, co możemy
natychmiast zobaczyć, patrząc na nią, i ma jedną wartość własną równą jeden i jedną wartość własną równą
zero, więc jest dodatnio półokreślona, a jej ślad jest równy jeden, więc jest macierzą gęstości, jak
oczekiwano. Możemy obliczyć macierze gęstości odpowiadające standardowej bazie i bazie plus-minus w podobny sposób, a te macierze gęstości
są tutaj pokazane. Oto jeszcze jeden przykład wektora stanu kwantowego, który przypadkowo
pojawił się dawno temu w pierwszej lekcji serii. Jeśli obliczymy sprzężoną transpozycję, a następnie pomnożymy,
otrzymamy macierz gęstości pokazaną tutaj. Ponownie jest hermitowska i ma
ślad równy jeden, a jeśli obliczysz wartości własne, przekonasz się, że znowu ma jedną wartość własną równą jeden i jedną
wartość własną równą zero. Przy okazji to jest wspólna cecha wszystkich stanów czystych – zawsze mają jedną wartość własną
równą jeden, a pozostałe wartości własne są wszystkie równe zero. Ogólnie rzecz biorąc, dla całkowicie dowolnego wektora
stanu kwantowego s o dowolnej liczbie wpisów, jeśli pomnożymy ket s przez bra s, otrzymamy
macierz gęstości, która wygląda tak. Zauważ w szczególności, że wpisy przekątniowe są zawsze jednym z
wpisów s przemnożonym przez jego własne sprzężone zespolone, co możemy alternatywnie wyrazić jako wartość bezwzględna podniesiona do kwadratu tego wpisu, i to jest
jeden ze sposobów zobaczenia, że ślad będzie zawsze równy jeden. Jest to też spójne z uwagą, którą poczyniłem wcześniej w lekcji o tym, że
wpisy przekątniowe macierzy gęstości mówią nam, jakie będą prawdopodobieństwa zobaczenia każdego możliwego klasycznego stanu,
jeśli przeprowadzimy pomiar w standardowej bazie. I jedna ostatnia uwaga tutaj:
nie ma problemu z globalnymi fazami dla macierzy gęstości. Dwa stany kwantowe są identyczne wtedy i tylko wtedy, gdy ich macierze
gęstości są równe. W szczególności załóżmy, że mamy dwa wektory stanu kwantowego s i fi, które
są równoważne z dokładnością do globalnej fazy, co oznacza, że możemy wyrazić jeden z nich – powiedzmy fi – jako drugi pomnożony przez
pewną liczbę zespoloną na okręgu jednostkowym. Jeśli obliczymy reprezentację gęstościową fi, to odkryjemy,
że czynnik globalnej fazy zostaje pomnożony przez własne sprzężone i to daje nam jeden, więc
efektywnie znika i pozostajemy dokładnie z tą samą macierzą gęstości, którą otrzymujemy z s. To jest więc
miły mały bonus, a bardziej ogólnie nie ma żadnych problemów z równoważnością z dokładnością do globalnych faz, gdy
pracujemy z macierzami gęstości. To jest zasadniczo degeneracja, która istnieje, gdy używamy wektorów stanu kwantowego, a nie
macierzy gęstości, do reprezentowania stanów kwantowych. Macierze gęstości posiadają kluczową właściwość, a mianowicie że kombinacje wypukłe
macierzy gęstości reprezentują probabilistyczne lub losowe wybory stanów
kwantowych. Innym sposobem powiedzenia tego jest to, że macierze gęstości można uśredniać razem w sensowny sposób, czego
nie możemy robić z wektorami stanu kwantowego. Żeby wyjaśnić to dokładniej, zacznijmy od sytuacji, w której
mamy dwie macierze gęstości rho i sigma reprezentujące stany kwantowe pewnego układu. Wyobraźmy sobie, że
układ jest przygotowywany w stanie rho z prawdopodobieństwem p, dla pewnego p między zerem a jeden, a w pozostałych przypadkach
układ jest przygotowywany w stanie sigma. Na przykład może p wynosi 1/2, więc
możemy sobie wyobrazić, że ktoś rzuca uczciwą monetą, a jeśli wypadnie orzeł, wykonuje pewien proces, który pozostawia układ w
stanie rho, a w przeciwnym razie, jeśli moneta wypadnie reszką, wykonuje inny proces, który pozostawia układ w
stanie sigma. Pytanie brzmi teraz: jaki jest stan układu? I żeby być precyzyjnym,
interesuje nas stan układu w izolacji, ignorując wszelkie inne informacje, które mogą istnieć o
tym, jakie przygotowanie zostało przeprowadzone. Na przykład wyobraź sobie, że nie mamy dostępu do monety ani do
pamięci osoby, która przeprowadzała przygotowanie stanu. I odpowiedź na to pytanie jest taka, że jest to po prostu ważona średnia dwóch macierzy
WEBVTT
gęstości: p razy rho plus 1 minus p razy sigma. To przy okazji jest zupełnie
analogiczne do tego, co mielibyśmy, gdyby rho i sigma nie były macierzami gęstości, ale raczej wektorami prawdopodobieństwa
reprezentującymi stany probabilistyczne. Nie jest to więc nic szokującego ani tajemniczego, lecz raczej coś,
co być może jest znajome z rachunku prawdopodobieństwa. Tego rodzaju uśrednianie robimy cały czas, gdy obliczamy prawdopodobieństwa i myślimy
o klasycznych losowych wyborach, a chodzi o to, że działa to też dla macierzy gęstości, ale zauważ, że nie działa
dla wektorów stanu kwantowego. To znaczy, ogólnie nie można uśredniać razem dwóch wektorów stanu
kwantowego w ten sposób i mieć nadziei na otrzymanie prawidłowego wektora stanu kwantowego. Jeśli spróbujesz, zwykle dostaniesz wektor, który
nie ma euklidesowej normy równej jeden. W przypadku macierzy gęstości jednak ważone średnie takie jak ta będą zawsze
prawidłowymi macierzami gęstości, a co ważniejsze, macierz gęstości, którą otrzymujesz, będzie reprezentować ten losowy wybór w
sensowny sposób. To uogólnia się na losowe wybory z więcej niż dwoma
alternatywami. W szczególności jeśli mamy m możliwych macierzy gęstości i wektor prawdopodobieństwa z m wpisami, po jednym
dla każdej macierzy gęstości, a układ jest przygotowywany w każdym możliwym stanie z odpowiadającym mu prawdopodobieństwem,
to ważona średnia tych macierzy gęstości opisuje wynikowy stan układu. Przy okazji, gdy
mówimy o kombinacji wypukłej macierzy gęstości, to właśnie to mamy na myśli. Kombinacja wypukła to po prostu kombinacja liniowa,
w której współczynniki tworzą wektor prawdopodobieństwa. Będzie to zawsze macierz
gęstości, a prostym i zwięzłym sposobem powiedzenia tego w terminach matematycznych jest to, że zbiór wszystkich macierzy gęstości
odpowiadających danemu układowi jest zbiorem wypukłym. Więc jeśli mamy powiedzmy m wektorów stanu
kwantowego s 0 przez s m minus jeden wraz z prawdopodobieństwami p 0 przez p m minus jeden, które łącznie tworzą
wektor prawdopodobieństwa, a układ jest przygotowywany w stanie s k z prawdopodobieństwem pk dla każdego k, to
wynikowy stan układu jest opisany przez macierz gęstości pokazaną tutaj na ekranie. W szczególności nie uśredniamy
razem wektorów stanu kwantowego, lecz raczej uśredniamy razem odpowiadające im macierze
gęstości. Ogólnie rzecz biorąc, taki stan nie będzie miał reprezentacji jako pojedynczy wektor stanu
kwantowego, chyba że dzieje się coś trywialnego, jak na przykład to, że wszystkie wektory stanu kwantowego są równoważne z dokładnością do globalnej fazy lub wszystkie poza jednym z
prawdopodobieństw są równe zero. Nie otrzymamy czystego stanu kwantowego z takiego procesu, lecz raczej to, co się
nazywa mieszanym stanem kwantowym, gdzie jest pewna nieodłączna niepewność. Przyjrzyjmy się prostemu
przykładowi. Załóżmy, że mamy qubit i z prawdopodobieństwem 1/2 qubit jest przygotowywany w stanie zero, a w przeciwnym razie
jest przygotowywany w stanie plus. Oto macierz gęstości, którą otrzymujemy przez uśrednianie, jak opisałem:
obliczamy macierze gęstości odpowiadające dwóm możliwym stanom, mnożymy przez odpowiadające prawdopodobieństwa i dodajemy
wyniki. To, co otrzymujemy, jest rzeczywiście macierzą gęstości, jest hermitowska, jej ślad jest równy jeden
i jeśli obliczysz wartości własne tej macierzy, otrzymasz dwie dodatnie liczby rzeczywiste, które przypadkowo są dwoma liczbami, które powinny być już znajome:
cosinus kwadrat z pi/8 i sinus kwadrat z pi/8, czyli około 0,85 i
0,15. Nie istnieje pojedynczy wektor stanu kwantowego reprezentujący ten stan – nie jest to stan czysty. Następnie przyjrzymy się pewnej
konkretnej macierzy gęstości, która reprezentuje stan kwantowy pojedynczego qubit zwany stanem całkowicie
mieszanym. Ten stan pojawia się często, więc dobrze mieć dla niego nazwę, i jest też dobrym przykładem, bo
ilustruje ważną cechę macierzy gęstości. Istnieje analogicznie zdefiniowany stan całkowicie mieszany dla każdego
układu, ale na razie skupimy się na tym stanie dla pojedynczego qubit, żeby zachować
prostotę. Załóżmy, że losowo ustawiamy stan qubit jako stan zero lub stan jeden, każdy z
prawdopodobieństwem 1/2 – podobnie jak jednorodny losowy bit. Możemy obliczyć reprezentację gęstościową tego
stanu w zwykły sposób: bierzemy średnią dwóch reprezentacji gęstościowych tych stanów. Oto jak to
wygląda w postaci macierzowej, i to, co otrzymujemy, to macierz jednostkowa podzielona przez
dwa. Ten stan jest znany jako stan całkowicie mieszany i zasadniczo reprezentuje całkowitą lub maksymalną
niepewność co do qubit, podobnie jak jednorodny wektor prawdopodobieństwa reprezentuje maksymalną niepewność w
klasycznym kontekście probabilistycznym. Ogólnie rzecz biorąc, dla dowolnego układu stan całkowicie mieszany to
stan, który otrzymujemy, jednolicie wybierając stan standardowej bazy, a reprezentacja gęstościowa będzie
macierzą jednostkową podzieloną przez wymiar, lub równoważnie liczbę klasycznych stanów tego
układu. W tym momencie to tylko terminologia, ale jeśli trochę zmienimy konfigurację, zobaczymy ważną cechę
macierzy gęstości. W szczególności zmieńmy procedurę i w
miejsce stanów standardowej bazy zero i jeden podstawmy stany plus i minus. Tym razem zaczynamy od
wyrażenia pokazanego na ekranie, ale jeśli przeprowadzamy arytmetykę, otrzymujemy dokładnie tę samą
macierz gęstości. To jest macierz jednostkowa podzielona przez dwa – więc to jest ten sam stan co poprzednio:
stan całkowicie mieszany. To, jak to się mówi, jest cechą, a nie błędem. Te dwie procedury są w istocie
różne, ale jeśli masz tylko wynikowy qubit, nie ma fizycznego sposobu, by je odróżnić
nawet statystycznie. Na przykład jeśli przeprowadziłeś pomiar w standardowej bazie na tym qubit
po wykonaniu pierwszej procedury, oczywiście uzyskałbyś wynik zero z prawdopodobieństwem 1/2 i wynik jeden z prawdopodobieństwem 1/2. Ale uzyskałbyś też
dokładnie te same prawdopodobieństwa wyników dla drugiej procedury, i to samo dotyczy każdego innego testu, który mógłbyś
wymyślić, zakładając, że testujesz tylko sam qubit. Ogólnie rzecz biorąc, macierze gęstości nie opisują, jak układ był
przygotowany – mówią tylko, co się stanie, jeśli będziesz coś z tym układem robić w przyszłości, niezależnie od tego, czy
przeprowadzasz operacje czy pomiary. I w rzeczywistości macierze gęstości są w tym
zakresie doskonałe: jeśli dwie różne alternatywy prowadzą do tej samej macierzy gęstości, nie można ich odróżnić nawet
statystycznie. Ale jeśli dwie macierze gęstości są różne, to będzie jakiś sposób, by je odróżnić – nie
koniecznie definitywnie, ale w sensie statystycznym. Gdy używamy ogólnego sformułowania informacji
WEBVTT
kwantowej, informacja klasyczna wyłania się zasadniczo jako szczególny przypadek i teraz wyjaśnię, jak to
działa. Konkretnie zobaczymy, jak stany probabilistyczne mogą być reprezentowane przez macierze
gęstości. Zacznijmy od stanów klasycznych, zaczynając od prostego
przykładu. Oto reprezentacje gęstościowe stanów zero i jeden standardowej bazy
qubit. Kojarzymy te stany z klasycznymi stanami 0 i 1, więc możemy myśleć o tych macierzach gęstości jako
reprezentujących te stany. To jest bardzo proste i możemy łatwo uogólnić
przykład. Jeśli mamy układ, którego klasyczny zbiór stanów to Sigma, to klasyczny stan a jest reprezentowany przez lub
skojarzony z macierzą gęstości ket a bra a. Ta macierz ma pojedynczy jeden w
wpisie przekątniowym, którego wiersz i kolumna odpowiadają klasycznemu stanowi a, a każdy inny wpis jest
zerem. Stany probabilistyczne są reprezentowane przez kombinacje wypukłe macierzy tej formy, co jest naturalne
ze względu na to, co wiemy o macierzach gęstości i ich działaniu, a konkretnie, że kombinacje wypukłe macierzy gęstości reprezentują losowe lub
probabilistyczne wybory stanów kwantowych. Na przykład załóżmy, że
mamy układ X, którego klasyczny zbiór stanów zawiera liczby całkowite 0 do n minus jeden, dla pewnej dodatniej liczby całkowitej n.
Oczywiście zakładając, że nasz klasyczny zbiór stanów ma tę postać, traci się mało lub wcale uogólnioności. Gdybyśmy mieli
inny klasyczny zbiór stanów, moglibyśmy po prostu zmienić nazwy klasycznych stanów w ten sposób, i często jest całkiem wygodnie zakładać, że nasze
klasyczne zbiory stanów wyglądają tak, w dużej mierze dlatego, że ułatwia to pisanie rzeczy wprost w terminach
wektorów i macierzy. Zakładając, że mamy stan probabilistyczny układu X
reprezentowany przez wektor prawdopodobieństwa w zwykły sposób, możemy skojarzyć ten stan probabilistyczny z macierzą
gęstości, jak pokazano na ekranie. Bierzemy ważoną średnią macierzy gęstości odpowiadających
różnym klasycznym stanom i to, co otrzymujemy, to diagonalna macierz gęstości. W szczególności widzimy prawdopodobieństwa
wzdłuż przekątnej tej macierzy, a każdy inny wpis jest równy zero. Oczywiście jest to macierz gęstości,
czego oczekujemy, ale możemy też to uzasadnić bezpośrednio: jest to macierz hermitowska, jej ślad
jest równy jeden, bo prawdopodobieństwa sumują się do jeden, a w przypadku macierzy diagonalnej wartości własne są wpisami przekątnymi
i są wszystkie nieujemne, bo są prawdopodobieństwami. Zauważ też, że każda
diagonalna macierz gęstości, czyli taka, której wszystkie wpisy poza przekątną są zerem, musi wyglądać tak. Więc w skrócie:
stany probabilistyczne można skojarzyć z diagonalnymi macierzami gęstości. Zauważ przy okazji, że jest to spójne z
nieformalną interpretacją wpisów macierzy gęstości, którą wspomniałem na początku lekcji. W szczególności nic nie jest w
kwantowej superpozycji – jest to zasadniczo tylko losowość klasyczna – i odpowiednio wszystkie wpisy poza przekątną
są zerem. Wcześniej w tej serii omawialiśmy twierdzenie spektralne i zrobiliśmy to
konkretnie dla macierzy unitarnych w kontekście estymacji fazy. Twierdzenie spektralne jest bardziej
ogólne niż to jednak, co oznacza, że mówi nam coś o szerszej klasie macierzy niż tylko macierzach
unitarnych. W szczególności stosuje się ono do klasy macierzy zwanych macierzami normalnymi, która obejmuje wszystkie macierze hermitowskie jak
również macierze unitarne. Co teraz zrobimy, to spojrzeć na inne sformułowanie tego twierdzenia, tym razem skupiając się tylko na
macierzach dodatnio półokreślonych, a następnie zobaczymy, że mówi nam ono coś bardzo interesującego i krytycznie ważnego o macierzach
gęstości. Załóżmy, że p jest dowolną macierzą dodatnio półokreśloną, co obejmuje dowolną macierz gęstości, jak również dowolną
macierz dodatnio półokreśloną, która nie ma śladu równego jeden. p jest dodatnio półokreślona, więc musi być
kwadratowa, czyli n na n dla pewnego n, i będziemy musieli odwoływać się do tej liczby n, więc niech n będzie
odpowiednio dobrane – albo inaczej: zakładamy, że p jest n na n. To, co twierdzenie mówi nam w tym przypadku, to
że musi istnieć baza ortonormalna wektorów, które nazwiemy s0 do s n minus jeden, wraz z nieujemnymi liczbami
rzeczywistymi lambda 0 do lambda n minus jeden, takimi że p można wyrazić jak pokazano
tutaj na ekranie. Innymi słowy, jeśli pomnożymy każde lambda k przez ket sk razy bra sk i następnie
zsumujemy po wszystkich k od 0 do n minus jeden, otrzymamy p. Nazywa się to rozkładem
spektralnym p. Każde lambda k jest z konieczności wartością własną p, a każde sk jest jednostkowym wektorem własnym p
odpowiadającym tej wartości własnej. Jeśli wrócisz do lekcji 7 o estymacji fazy, znajdziesz podobne twierdzenie
dla macierzy unitarnych. Tam wartości własne są liczbami zespolonymi na okręgu jednostkowym, a nie nieujemnymi liczbami
rzeczywistymi, ale poza tym jest to ta sama idea, i są to naprawdę tylko dwa szczególne przypadki bardziej ogólnego twierdzenia, zwanego
twierdzeniem spektralnym. Nie działa dla każdej macierzy – macierz musi komutować ze swoją
własną sprzężoną transpozycją, i to właśnie oznacza, że macierz jest normalna. Ale w istocie zawsze mamy
to zarówno dla macierzy unitarnych, jak i dla macierzy dodatnio półokreślonych, jak również dla macierzy hermitowskich bardziej ogólnie, gdzie
zawsze będziemy mieć rzeczywiste wartości własne, ale niekoniecznie nieujemne. To jest więc sformułowanie
twierdzenia spektralnego tylko dla macierzy dodatnio półokreślonych, a teraz zobaczmy, co mówi nam ono o macierzach
gęstości. To, co nam mówi, to to, że dla dowolnej macierzy gęstości n na n możemy zawsze wyrazić tę macierz jako kombinację wypukłą
n stanów czystych, a co więcej, możemy wziąć te n stanów czystych jako
ortogonalne. To wynika dość bezpośrednio z twierdzenia razem z podstawowym faktem z algebry liniowej, a mianowicie, że
suma wartości własnych dowolnej macierzy jest zawsze równa śladowi tej macierzy. Innymi słowy, wszystko, co robimy, to
zmiana nazw wartości własnych na p 0 przez p n minus jeden, a następnie obserwowanie, że gdy to robimy i
zbieramy te wartości własne do wektora n-wymiarowego, z konieczności otrzymujemy wektor prawdopodobieństwa, bo muszą być wszystkie nieujemne i ich suma jest równa
śladowi rho, który wynosi jeden, bo rho jest macierzą gęstości. To jest więc dość proste, ale
konceptualnie naprawdę fundamentalne. To, co nam mówi, to to, że każda macierz gęstości, bez względu na to, jak skomplikowana może się
wydawać, mogłaby powstać przez najpierw wybranie bazy ortonormalnej jakiegokolwiek układu,
o którym mówimy, a następnie losowe wybranie stanu kwantowego z tej bazy zgodnie z pewnym wyborem prawdopodobieństw.
WEBVTT
Jeśli nie jest od razu jasne, dlaczego to jest interesujące lub ważne, to w porządku, ale istotnie używamy tego
faktu bardzo często, gdy wnioskujemy o macierzach gęstości, i w istocie wyrażanie danej macierzy gęstości
w ten sposób jest często pierwszą rzeczą, którą robimy, gdy chcemy ją zrozumieć
lepiej. Oto przykład. Przypomnij sobie macierz gęstości, którą opracowaliśmy wcześniej, gdzie losowo wybieraliśmy między
stanem zero a stanem plus, każdy z prawdopodobieństwem 1/2, która jak obliczyliśmy ma macierz gęstości, która
wygląda tak. Stan zero i stan plus nie są ortogonalne, więc to nie jest
rozkład spektralny. Ale jeśli obliczymy jeden – co możemy zrobić komputerowo lub ręcznie w takim przypadku jak ten – to co
otrzymujemy, to to wyrażenie naszej macierzy gęstości, gdzie wartości własne to te liczby, które ciągle się pojawiają, a
odpowiadające im wektory własne możemy wybrać jak pokazano tutaj na ekranie. I znowu widzieliśmy te wektory wcześniej, na przykład w
kontekście gry CHSH w lekcji czwartej. To jest więc interesujące: zgodnie z
pierwotnym wyrażeniem ten stan jest tym, co otrzymujemy, równomiernie wybierając między dwoma stanami: stanem zero i
stanem plus. Ale w istocie otrzymujemy dokładnie tę samą macierz gęstości, losowo wybierając między dwoma czystymi
stanami, ale z bardzo silnym obciążeniem na korzyść jednego z nich: około 85% dla pierwszego i tylko około 15% dla
drugiego. Więc w pewnym sensie jest tu faktycznie znacznie mniej losowości niż mogło się to pierwotnie
wydawać. Istnieje bardzo ładny geometryczny sposób myślenia o i wizualizowania stanów kwantowych pojedynczego qubit, zwany
sferą Blocha. Działa to tylko dla pojedynczych qubit – dla układów mających trzy
lub więcej klasycznych stanów, w tym dwa lub więcej qubit razem, już nie działa. Jest więc dość ograniczone, ale
niemniej jest to świetny sposób myślenia o stanach pojedynczego qubit. Można by było go wprowadzić już dawno temu
w lekcji pierwszej serii o pojedynczych układach, ale nie jest to tak naprawdę niezbędne do zrozumienia działania informacji kwantowej, i ma też
naprawdę ładne połączenie z macierzami gęstości, więc naturalnie pasuje do tej lekcji. I w istocie zamierzam go wyjaśnić
nieco inaczej, niż jest to być może najbardziej typowo wyjaśniane – używając macierzy gęstości do efektywnego
wyznaczenia go. Więc jeśli już znasz sferę Blocha, to wyjaśnienie może być trochę inne od tego,
jak się o niej najpierw dowiedziałeś, ale na końcu powinno być oczywiście równoważne. Zaczniemy od myślenia o
możliwych stanach czystych qubit, najpierw reprezentowanych przez wektory stanu
kwantowego. Z dokładnością do globalnej fazy każdy wektor stanu kwantowego qubit można wyrazić jak
pokazano tutaj na ekranie. Żeby być precyzyjnym, mamy dwie liczby rzeczywiste theta i fi i będziemy myśleć
o tych dwóch liczbach jako kątach wyrażonych w radianach. Pierwsza liczba theta jest między 0 a pi, czyli równoważnie jest
kątem między 0 a 180°, a druga liczba fi jest między 0 a 2 pi, włącznie z 0, ale nie z 2
pi – czyli jest to dowolny kąt między 0 a 360°. Wpis zerowy naszego wektora to
cosinus z theta/2, więc jest to liczba rzeczywista między 0 a 1, a w szczególności jest z konieczności nieujemna.
A wpis jedynkowy naszego wektora to e do potęgi i razy fi razy sinus z theta/2, i to może być
dowolna liczba zespolona na okręgu jednostkowym lub wewnątrz niego. Jest to zawsze wektor jednostkowy, czyli
inaczej mówiąc, jest prawidłowym wektorem stanu kwantowego, i dla każdego danego wektora stanu qubit zawsze możemy znaleźć
wektor tej postaci, który jest równoważny temu wektorowi z dokładnością do globalnej fazy. W szczególności zawsze możemy
pomnożyć dany wektor przez globalną fazę, żeby uczynić wpis zerowy nieujemną liczbą rzeczywistą, wybrać takie theta,
które daje nam ten wpis, a następnie dobrać fi, żeby pasowało do wpisu jedynkowego. Wartość bezwzględna wpisu jedynkowego będzie
z konieczności zawsze zgadzać się z sinusem theta/2, przy założeniu, że zaczęliśmy od wektora
jednostkowego. Nie jest całkiem tak, że theta i fi są jednoznacznie wyznaczone przez jakikolwiek wektor stanu kwantowego, od którego zaczęliśmy,
ale prawie. Zawsze będzie unikalna wartość theta między zerem a pi, która działa,
i zazwyczaj jest unikalna wartość fi, która działa, ale w dwóch szczególnych przypadkach tak nie jest. W szczególności, jeśli zaczęliśmy od
stanu standardowej bazy, to theta będzie zero albo pi, i w obu przypadkach nie ma znaczenia, co fi – jest
całkowicie nieistotne. Gdy theta jest zero, cosinus z theta/2 wynosi 1, a sinus z theta/2
wynosi zero, więc mnożymy e do potęgi i razy fi przez zero, więc nie ma żadnego znaczenia, co fi.
A jeśli theta jest pi, to tym razem cosinus wynosi zero, a sinus wynosi jeden, więc mamy e do potęgi i razy fi razy ket 1, ale te
wektory są wszystkie równoważne z dokładnością do globalnej fazy, więc znowu nie ma znaczenia, co fi. Jeśli jednak theta leży właściwie
między zerem a pi, to zawsze będzie unikalna wartość fi, która działa. Przy okazji ta możliwa
degeneracja wartości fi dla dwóch szczególnych przypadków nabierze doskonałego sensu, gdy zobaczymy geometryczny obraz
za chwilę. Teraz obliczmy macierz gęstości skojarzoną z wektorem stanu postaci, którą właśnie
zidentyfikowaliśmy. Jest to więc stan czysty qubit. Żeby to zrobić, mnożymy wektor
przez jego sprzężoną transpozycję jak zwykle, i na ekranie jest wyrażenie macierzy, którą otrzymujemy przez obliczenie sprzężonej
transpozycji i wykonanie mnożenia. Teraz, podobnie jak każda macierz 2x2,
istnieje unikalny sposób na uzyskanie tej macierzy przez wzięcie kombinacji liniowej macierzy Pauliego
włącznie z macierzą jednostkową. W szczególności możemy uzyskać tę macierz, wybierając współczynniki
macierzy Pauliego jak pokazano tutaj na ekranie. Umieszczamy dwa w mianowniku, bo to sprawi, że
wszystko ładnie się ułoży – nic nas do tego nie zmusza, ale możemy to zrobić i będzie to pomocne. Ale poza
tą kosmetyczną decyzją nie ma tu żadnej swobody – jest to jedyny sposób na uzyskanie tej macierzy przez wzięcie kombinacji liniowej macierzy Pauliego. Dzieje się tak,
bo macierze Pauliego włącznie z macierzą jednostkową stanowią bazę przestrzeni wektorowej wszystkich macierzy 2x2. Jednym ze sposobów
sprawdzenia poprawności tego wyrażenia jest skorzystanie z podstawowych tożsamości trygonometrycznych, a w szczególności jeśli na chwilę się odsunę,
mamy tutaj pewne tożsamości, które umożliwią to sprawdzenie. Więc jeśli masz ochotę, zatrzymaj film lub
zrób zrzut ekranu i sprawdź, czy możesz uzyskać drugie wyrażenie macierzy gęstości na dole z pierwszego. Podsumowując, każdy stan czysty
qubit wyrażony jako macierz gęstości może być zapisany jako kombinacja liniowa macierzy Pauliego jak pokazano na
WEBVTT
ekranie, dla theta między 0 a pi i fi między 0 a 2 pi. Zauważ, że mamy dokładnie tę samą
degenerację co poprzednio, a mianowicie że fi jest nieistotne, gdy theta wynosi zero lub pi, i tym razem możemy to
widzieć wyraźniej, bo sinus z theta wynosi zero w tych dwóch przypadkach, a w pozostałych nie. Warto zauważyć,
że w tej formule theta pojawia się jako argument funkcji sinus i cosinus, a nie theta/2 jak w oryginalnej wersji wektora stanu
kwantowego, i dzieje się tak, bo użyliśmy tych tożsamości trygonometrycznych, z których pierwsze trzy są zasadniczo
przekształceniami tak zwanych wzorów na funkcje kąta podwójnego, więc kąt efektywnie się podwaja. I teraz w końcu jesteśmy gotowi
porozmawiać o samej sferze Blocha. Skupimy się na trzech współczynnikach macierzy Pauliego bez macierzy jednostkowej
w liczniku wyrażenia naszej macierzy gęstości, więc ignorujemy dwa w
mianowniku. Ignorujemy też macierz jednostkową, bo jej współczynnik nigdy się nie zmienia – dzieje się tak, bo ten
współczynnik jest wyznaczony przez ślad jakiejkolwiek macierzy, którą wyrażamy, a macierze gęstości zawsze mają ślad równy
jeden. Wyobraź teraz sobie, że mamy trzy osie oznaczone x, y i z, zorientowane zgodnie z
tak zwaną regułą prawej ręki, i rozważamy punkt, którego współrzędne odpowiadają trzem współczynnikom. I żeby być precyzyjnym,
mówimy o zwykłej trójwymiarowej przestrzeni, gdzie współrzędne są zawsze liczbami rzeczywistymi.
Współrzędna x odpowiada współczynnikowi macierzy Pauliego sigma x w liczniku naszego wyrażenia, który jest zawsze liczbą rzeczywistą, bo macierze
gęstości są hermitowskie, i analogicznie dla y i z. To, co znajdujemy, to że ten punkt,
który uzyskujemy, jest zawsze na sferze jednostkowej, czyli innymi słowy na sferze o promieniu
jeden. W szczególności jest to punkt, który otrzymujemy, jeśli zaczynamy od punktu, gdzie dodatnia oś z przecina sferę
– co możemy myśleć o jako o biegunie północnym – obracamy się w kierunku dodatniej osi x o kąt theta, a następnie
obracamy w kierunku dodatniej osi y, czyli innymi słowy na wschód, o kąt fi. W tym kontekście kąt theta
jest zwany kątem biegunowym, co jest łatwe do zapamiętania, bo zaczyna od bieguna, a fi jest zwany kątem
azymutowym, i razem te dwa kąty reprezentują współrzędne sferyczne dla punktów na sferze jednostkowej. Jeśli
chcesz, możesz też pozwolić, by promień się zmieniał, żeby reprezentować dowolne punkty w przestrzeni trójwymiarowej, ale tutaj skupiamy się na punktach na
sferze jednostkowej, gdzie promień jest równy jeden. Możesz też myśleć o theta jako reprezentującym szerokość geograficzną, z wyjątkiem tego, że idziemy
od 0 do 180° od bieguna północnego do bieguna południowego, a nie plus minus 90° od równika, a fi reprezentuje
długość geograficzną, gdzie zasadniczo definiujemy południk zerowy jako południk przecinający dodatnią
oś x. Jeśli, tak jak ja, masz trudność z zapamiętaniem, która z nich to szerokość, a która to długość geograficzna, może być pomocne zapamiętanie,
że długość (longitude) odpowiada przedziałowi, który jest dłuższy: 2 pi, w odróżnieniu od
pi. W każdym razie punkt, który uzyskujemy na sferze jednostkowej z naszego wektora stanu qubit s, myśląc o współrzędnych w ten
sposób, jest reprezentacją Blocha stanu kwantowego odpowiadającego s. Gdy myślimy o całej
trójwymiarowej sferze jednostkowej w ten sposób, otrzymujemy sferę Blocha. Geometrycznie to jest po prostu sfera jednostkowa
w zwykłej przestrzeni trójwymiarowej, ale w istocie jest to geometria stanów
qubit. Mamy tu doskonałą bijekcję: każdy czysty stan qubit odpowiada unikalnemu punktowi na
sferze, a każdy punkt na sferze reprezentuje unikalny stan qubit z dokładnością do globalnej fazy. Gdy pracujemy z
wektorami stanu kwantowego, ta korespondencja bywa też inaczej nazywana – na przykład czasami mówi się o sferze Poincarégo.
Ale w kontekście informacji kwantowej jest ona ogólnie nazywana sferą Blocha. Zauważ, że możemy teraz zobaczyć
degenerację kąta fi całkiem wyraźnie, bo długość geograficzna nie ma znaczenia na biegunie północnym i południowym. Ale poza
biegunami każdy punkt na Ziemi ma unikalne współrzędne w terminach szerokości i długości geograficznej, i to samo dzieje się tutaj. Tak więc tak
działa sfera Blocha ogólnie rzecz biorąc. Przyjrzyjmy się teraz kilku konkretnym przykładom stanów qubit i
temu, gdzie leżą na sferze Blocha. Zacznijmy od standardowej bazy. Oto punkty, które uzyskujemy,
gdy kąt biegunowy theta wynosi zero dla stanu zero i pi dla stanu jeden. Są to dwa przypadki, gdy
kąt azymutalny fi jest nieistotny, jak już omawiałem. Możemy też wyrazić odpowiadające im macierze gęstości jako kombinacje
liniowe macierzy Pauliego. W każdym razie dochodzimy do wniosku, że te dwa stany odpowiadają biegunowi północnemu i
biegunowi południowemu sfery Blocha. Stan zero jest na górze, a stan jeden jest na
dole. Następnie znajdźmy stany plus i minus na sferze Blocha. Znowu możemy myśleć albo o
wektorach stanu kwantowego, albo o macierzach gęstości. Dla wektorów stanu kwantowego tym razem kąt biegunowy theta musi wynosić pi
przez 2, żeby zerowy wpis wynosił 1/pierwiastek z 2. Kąt azymutalny fi musi wynosić zero
dla stanu plus, bo jedynkowy wpis jest dodatni dla stanu plus, i musi wynosić pi, czyli 180°, dla stanu minus,
bo ten jedynkowy wpis jest ujemny w tym przypadku. Więc te dwa punkty leżą na
równiku sfery Blocha. Stan plus jest tam, gdzie dodatnia oś x przecina sferę, a stan minus jest po przeciwnej stronie, gdzie
ujemna oś x przecina sferę. Równoważnie możemy też to zobaczyć z wyrażeń macierzy Pauliego dla
odpowiadających im macierzy gęstości: współrzędne y i z są obie równe zero, natomiast współrzędne x są dodatnie i
ujemne 1. Innym przykładem jest baza plus i minus i, która jest podobna do bazy plus-minus, z wyjątkiem tego, że mnożymy też
jedynkowy wpis przez i – jednostkę urojoną. Stan plus i widzieliśmy wcześniej w lekcji, a stan minus i jest zdefiniowany
w analogiczny sposób. Kąt biegunowy theta jest taki sam jak dla stanów plus i minus: pi
przez 2, i tym razem musimy wybrać kąt azymutalny fi tak, żeby uzyskać i i minus i zamiast 1 i minus 1,
a pi/2 i 3 pi/2 to właściwe wybory, żeby to uzyskać. Możemy też ponownie spojrzeć na
opisy gęstościowe tych stanów, i sytuacja jest dość podobna do poprzednich dwóch przykładów, z wyjątkiem tego, że tym razem mamy macierz Pauliego sigma y zamiast
sigma z lub sigma x. Więc na sferze Blocha te dwa stany są zlokalizowane tam, gdzie oś y
przecina sferę. Jeśli trochę to uporządkujemy, możemy wyraźniej zobaczyć, jak sześć stanów, które właśnie omówiliśmy,
ma się do siebie nawzajem. Dla jeszcze jednego przykładu – a właściwie klasy przykładów – rozważmy
wektory stanu qubit, które pojawiły się wcześniej i w lekcji czwartej, gdzie zerowy wpis to cosinus z alpha dla pewnej liczby rzeczywistej alpha, a jedynkowy wpis to
WEBVTT
sinus z alpha. Możemy, przy okazji, ograniczyć uwagę do wartości alpha między zerem a pi, bo każda
inna wartość alpha da nam wektor, który jest równoważny z dokładnością do globalnej fazy do takiego, gdzie alpha jest w tym
przedziale. Jeśli obliczymy macierze gęstości skojarzone z tymi stanami wyrażone jako kombinacje liniowe macierzy Pauliego,
otrzymamy wyrażenie, które jest tutaj pokazane na ekranie. To obliczenie nie jest tutaj pokazane, ale to jest to, co powinieneś
uzyskać, jeśli przez to przejdziesz. I to, co stwierdzamy, to że te stany tworzą tak zwany wielki krąg przechodzący
przez bieguny. Konkretnie zaczyna się od bieguna północnego, gdy alpha wynosi zero, idzie w dół przez południk zerowy i
trafia na biegun południowy, gdy alpha wynosi pi/2, a następnie wraca do bieguna północnego po przeciwnej stronie sfery, gdy alpha rośnie od pi/2 do
pi. I to wszystko ma sens, bo po pierwsze, są to wektory rzeczywiste, więc część urojona jest zawsze zerem, a po
drugie, kąt alpha efektywnie podwaja się na sferze Blocha, i znowu można to wytłumaczyć
użyciem wzorów na funkcje kąta podwójnego. Widzieliśmy, że sfera Blocha zapewnia bardzo ładną geometryczną reprezentację stanów czystych
qubit, gdzie każdy punkt na sferze odpowiada unikalnemu stanowi czystemu qubit i odwrotnie.
Gdy mówimy o kuli Blocha, mamy na myśli wszystkie punkty na sferze Blocha, jak również punkty
zawarte wewnątrz niej. Punkty we wnętrzu kuli Blocha też odpowiadają stanom qubit –
konkretnie stanom, które nie są stanami czystymi. Innymi słowy, są to stany qubit, które można reprezentować macierzami gęstości, ale nie wektorami stanu qubit.
Fundamentalnym aspektem kuli Blocha i sposobu, w jaki punkty wnętrza reprezentują stany nieczyst, jest to, że
kombinacje wypukłe punktów wewnątrz kuli Blocha odpowiadają kombinacjom wypukłym macierzy gęstości.
Intuicyjnie mówiąc, oznacza to, że geometria działa doskonale nawet wewnątrz kuli
Blocha. Przyjrzyjmy się kilku przykładom, zaczynając od centralnego punktu kuli Blocha, który reprezentuje
stan całkowicie mieszany. Stan całkowicie mieszany otrzymujemy przez uśrednienie stanów zero i jeden, co jest spójne z faktem,
że środek sfery jest dokładnie w połowie drogi między biegunem północnym a biegunem południowym, a w istocie jest w połowie drogi między dowolnymi dwoma punktami antypodalnymi, takimi jak
stany plus i minus, oraz stany plus i i minus i. Punkty antypolarne na sferze Blocha zawsze odpowiadają
ortogonalnym stanom czystym, i to co to ujawnia lub odzwierciedla, to że zawsze możemy napisać stan całkowicie mieszany
jako średnią między dowolnymi dwoma ortogonalnymi czystymi stanami qubit. Innym sposobem zobaczenia tego jest
pomyślenie o reprezentacji macierzy Pauliego stanu całkowicie mieszanego. Żeby to zadziałało, musimy ustawić
współczynniki przy wszystkich trzech macierzach Pauliego bez macierzy jednostkowej na zero, więc odpowiedni punkt wewnątrz
kuli Blocha jest dokładnie w centrum, w miejscu początku układu współrzędnych. Przy okazji, myślenie o reprezentacjach macierzy Pauliego macierzy
gęstości w ten sposób faktycznie dość jasno pokazuje, że kombinacje wypukłe punktów kuli Blocha odpowiadają kombinacjom wypukłym
macierzy gęstości. Jeśli bierzemy średnią lub ważoną średnią macierzy gęstości i
wyrażamy wszystko w terminach kombinacji liniowych macierzy Pauliego, to oczywiście uśredniamy odpowiadające im punkty, bo wszystko
jest liniowe w tych trzech współczynnikach. Dla jeszcze jednego przykładu rozważmy średnią stanu zero
i stanu plus, którą widzieliśmy wcześniej w lekcji. Obliczyliśmy reprezentację gęstościową, która jest pokazana na
ekranie, i mamy, że punkt jest we wnętrzu kuli Blocha, w połowie drogi między stanami zero i plus.
Widzieliśmy też, że możemy wyrazić tę macierz gęstości w inny sposób na podstawie jej rozkładu spektralnego,
i znowu jest to spójne z diagramem i poprzednimi przykładami. I na tym kończy się
omówienie sfery Blocha i kuli Blocha. Ludzie często pytają, czy istnieje sfera Blocha lub kula Blocha dla układów mających
trzy lub więcej klasycznych stanów, i niestety odpowiedź brzmi: niekoniecznie. Zawsze możemy myśleć o
stanach kwantowych układu w terminach geometrycznych podobnych do kuli Blocha i otrzymamy ciało wypukłe w rzeczywistej przestrzeni
wektorowej, ale jeśli mamy trzy lub więcej klasycznych stanów, nie będzie ono sferyczne. Na przykład jeśli mamy
dokładnie trzy klasyczne stany, czyli qutrit w skrócie, otrzymamy ciało wypukłe w przestrzeni
ośmiowymiarowej, ale skrajne punkty tego ciała, które odpowiadają stanom czystym qutritu, będą tylko
czterowymiarowe. Jeśli możesz sobie wyobrazić wzięcie czterowymiarowej rozmaitości w przestrzeni ośmiowymiarowej i jakoś owinięcie jej, żeby uzyskać ciało
wypukłe, i uważasz, że to pomocny sposób myślenia o qutritach, to gratuluję. To jest interesujące, żeby
o tym myśleć, ale to nie jest kula, jest bardziej skomplikowane. W ostatniej części lekcji krótko omówimy
działanie macierzy gęstości dla wielu układów. Macierze gęstości mogą reprezentować stany wielu układów i to
działa w sposób całkowicie analogiczny do wektorów stanu kwantowego. W szczególności, podobnie jak w uproszczonym sformułowaniu informacji
kwantowej, możemy traktować wiele układów razem, jakby były jednym złożonym
układem. Tym razem zarówno wiersze, jak i kolumny macierzy gęstości reprezentujących stany wielu układów są
przypisane do iloczynu kartezjańskiego klasycznych zbiorów stanów poszczególnych układów. Na przykład możemy rozważyć
reprezentacje gęstościowe czterech stanów Bella, które otrzymujemy dokładnie tak jak dla innych wektorów
stanu kwantowego wcześniej w lekcji, mnożąc wektory stanów przez ich sprzężone transpozycje, i wyniki są tutaj pokazane na
ekranie. W istocie na poziomie konceptualnym nie ma tu nic nowego, choć za chwilę zobaczymy, że istnieją pewne
nowe rzeczy, które możemy robić z macierzami gęstości dla wielu układów. Pojęcia niezależności i
korelacji przenoszą się z wektorów stanu kwantowego na macierze gęstości, i w szczególności stwierdzamy, że iloczyny tensorowe
macierzy gęstości reprezentują niezależność między układami. Używamy tej samej terminologii, której
używaliśmy dla wektorów stanu kwantowego. Na przykład jeśli mamy układ X przygotowany w stanie rho i układ Y
przygotowany niezależnie w stanie sigma, to stan pary XY razem jest dany przez iloczyn tensorowy
rho i sigma. Nazywamy to stanem produktowym, i uogólnia się to w naturalny sposób na więcej niż dwa
układy. Macierze gęstości, których nie można wyrazić jako stany produktowe, reprezentują korelacje między układami, i ta
część jest podobna do wektorów stanu kwantowego, ale okazuje się, że istnieją różne typy korelacji, które mogą pojawić się, gdy używamy macierzy gęstości, nawet dla
tylko dwóch układów. W przeciwieństwie do tego, dla wektorów stanu kwantowego naprawdę istnieje tylko jeden typ korelacji, który możemy mieć,
i to jest splątanie. Innymi słowy, korelacja i splątanie są synonimami dla wektorów stanu kwantowego, ale
WEBVTT
to nieprawda dla macierzy gęstości. Tutaj rzeczy są bardziej interesujące. Na przykład możemy opisywać
skorelowane stany klasyczne z macierzami gęstości. Oto przykład macierzy gęstości reprezentującej klasyczny losowy
bit współdzielony między Alice i Bobem. Zawsze mają ten sam klasyczny stan – zero lub jeden – a prawdopodobieństwo wynosi
1/2 dla każdej z możliwości. Nie jest to stan splątany – splątanie jest nieklasyczne – ale
jest to stan skorelowany. Innym przykładem jest pojęcie powiązane z pojęciem ansamblu stanów kwantowych,
który możesz myśleć jako rozkład prawdopodobieństwa na skończonym zbiorze stanów kwantowych. W szczególności wyobraź sobie, że
mamy m macierzy gęstości rho zero przez rho m minus jeden, wszystkie reprezentujące możliwe stany danego układu,
wraz z prawdopodobieństwem narysowania każdej z nich. Gdybyśmy chcieli, moglibyśmy obliczyć ważoną średnią tych macierzy gęstości
przez wzięcie ich kombinacji wypukłej, ale to nie powiedziałoby nam, jakie były poszczególne stany ani jakie
były prawdopodobieństwa. Co możemy zamiast tego zrobić – i bywa to całkiem użyteczne – to rozważyć macierz
gęstości postaci pokazanej tutaj na ekranie. Jest to stan dwóch układów, gdzie pierwszy układ ma jeden klasyczny
stan dla każdej z alternatyw, i bierzemy ważoną średnią m stanów produktowych, gdzie stan pierwszego
układu jest zawsze klasyczny i zasadniczo etykietuje, który z m stanów mamy dla drugiego
układu. Jeśli nie jest jasne dokładnie, dlaczego chcielibyśmy myśleć o stanach w ten sposób, to w porządku – to jest tylko przykład
rodzaju korelacji, gdzie pierwszy układ jest zawsze klasyczny, a drugi układ może być w stanie
kwantowym. Trzecią kategorią możliwie skorelowanych stanów jest zbiór tak zwanych stanów
separowalnych. Mówiąc prosto, są to kombinacje wypukłe stanów produktowych, i zasadniczo reprezentują stany kwantowe,
gdzie wszelkie korelacje między układami są korelacjami klasycznymi. Jednym ze sposobów myślenia o
stanach takich jak ten jest to, że dokonujemy probabilistycznego wyboru liczby k, a następnie niezależnie przygotowujemy dwa
układy w stanie kwantowym, który może zależeć od tego wyboru k. Co jest może najbardziej interesujące w
stanach tej postaci, to że właśnie tak definiujemy splątanie w terminach matematycznych. W szczególności splątanie jest
definiowane jako brak separowalności. Więc jeśli masz macierz gęstości i nie jest możliwe wyrażenie jej w postaci
takiej jak ta, to z definicji jest ona splątana. Nawiązywałem do tego w lekcji czwartej i tutaj jest to nieco
bardziej szczegółowo. Przy okazji może być bardzo trudno stwierdzić, czy dana macierz gęstości reprezentuje splątany
stan, nawet przy pomocy komputera. Matematycznie i obliczeniowo rzecz biorąc, splątanie jest
rzeczywiście dość skomplikowane. Wspomniałem na początku lekcji, że jest jedna bardzo ważna rzecz, którą możemy robić z macierzami gęstości, a
mianowicie opisywanie stanów izolowanych części układów, nawet gdy są skorelowane i możliwie splątane z innymi
układami. Termin „stan zredukowany" jest często używany w tym kontekście, a jako prosty przykład obliczymy stany zredukowane
dla poszczególnych qubit tworzących ebit. Żeby być precyzyjnym, załóżmy, że
Alice i Bob dzielą ebit. Alice ma qubit A, Bob ma qubit B, i razem te dwa qubit są w stanie phi
plus. Pytanie, które rozważymy, brzmi: jaki jest stan qubit A Alice w
izolacji? Oczywiście moglibyśmy zadać to samo pytanie o qubit Boba, ale łatwo na nie odpowiedzieć, gdy znamy odpowiedź na to
pytanie. Teraz może być kuszące powiedzenie, że nie możemy opisać stanu qubit Alice w izolacji, bo jest on
splątany z qubit Boba, co mogłoby jakoś zabraniać nam opisywania lub nawet myślenia o stanie A w
izolacji, ale jest to fałsz. Prawdą jest, że nie możemy opisać stanu A wektorem
stanu kwantowego, bo jak zobaczymy, nie jest on w stanie czystym. Ale każdy układ ma stan w każdej chwili, który można
opisać macierzą gęstości, niezależnie od tego, czy jest splątany z innym układem czy nie. Jako eksperyment myślowy, żeby pomóc
nam zobaczyć, jaka jest odpowiedź na to pytanie, załóżmy, że Bob postanawia zabrać swój qubit i polecieć między gwiazdy i nigdy więcej o nim nie
słyszymy. Ale wyobraź sobie, że gdzieś po drodze postanawia przeprowadzić pomiar standardowej bazy na swoim
qubicie. Cóż, wiemy, jak obliczyć prawdopodobieństwa dla niego na uzyskanie dwóch możliwych wyników, i wiemy też, jaki będzie
stan A dla każdego możliwego wyniku, i te rzeczy są podsumowane w tej tabeli. W szczególności z prawdopodobieństwem 1/2
A zostanie w stanie zero, a z prawdopodobieństwem 1/2 A zostanie w stanie jeden. Więc jak omawiano wcześniej w
lekcji, pozostawia to A w stanie całkowicie mieszanym, i to jest odpowiedź
na nasze pytanie. Możesz teraz zaprotestować i powiedzieć, że to zależy od faktu, że
Bob zdecydował się zmierzyć swój qubit, i że założenie, że to robi, jest częścią historii, która doprowadziła nas do tej odpowiedzi. Ale
jeśli Bob jest lata świetlne stąd w momencie, gdy mierzy, nic, co robi, nie może mieć żadnego wpływu na żaden
eksperyment, który Alice może zdecydować się przeprowadzić na swoim qubicie – bo inaczej mielibyśmy komunikację
szybszą od światła. Więc qubit Alice jest w stanie całkowicie mieszanym niezależnie od tego, czy Bob
mierzy. Powinienem jasno powiedzieć w tym momencie, że pojęcie stanu zredukowanego i sposób jego definiowania nie mają tak naprawdę żadnej zależności od teorii względności
ani niemożliwości komunikacji szybszej od światła. To jest tylko sposób na wyjaśnienie tego w, miejmy nadzieję, intuicyjny sposób.
W rzeczywistości istnieje definicja matematyczna, którą zobaczymy w bardziej ogólnym kontekście za chwilę. Jest ona spójna z tą odpowiedzią
i zbieżnie z niemożliwością komunikacji szybszej od światła. Nie ma też żadnej innej
definicji, która byłaby spójna z informacją kwantową tak jak ją znamy. Rozważmy teraz stany zredukowane w większej
ogólności. Załóżmy, że mamy parę układów A i B, niekoniecznie qubit, które razem są w stanie czystym
reprezentowanym przez wektor stanu kwantowego s. Znowu skupiamy się na stanie zredukowanym układu A, i żeby to zrobić,
pomocne będzie myślenie o klasycznych stanach układu B. Więc niech gamma będzie tym zbiorem
klasycznych stanów b. Jak omawiano wcześniej, na przykład w lekcji drugiej serii,
istnieje unikalna kolekcja wektorów fi b dla każdego b w gamma, dla których wyrażenie s pokazane na ekranie
jest poprawne. W szczególności jest prosty wzór na te wektory: po prostu mnożymy wektor s przez
iloczyn tensorowy macierzy jednostkowej odpowiadającej układowi A z bra b dla jakiegokolwiek b, który nas interesuje.
To, co tutaj robimy, to zasadniczo przygotowywanie się do obliczenia tego, co by się stało, gdybyśmy przeprowadzili pomiar standardowej bazy
WEBVTT
na B, i znowu zostało to omówione w lekcji drugiej
serii. Więc załóżmy, że przeprowadziliśmy pomiar standardowej bazy na B. Każdy możliwy wynik pojawiłby się wtedy
z prawdopodobieństwem równym euklidesowej normie kwadrat odpowiadającego wektora fi b, a przy założeniu, że
uzyskaliśmy konkretny wynik b, normalizujemy wektor fi b, żeby określić wynikowy stan
A. Stosując to samo rozumowanie co w przykładzie ebitu sprzed chwili, otrzymujemy wyrażenie pokazane na
ekranie dla stanu zredukowanego A jako macierzy gęstości. Przy okazji norma do kwadratu w mianowniku pochodzi z
pomnożenia znormalizowanego wektora przez jego sprzężoną transpozycję, więc podnosimy normę euklidesową dwa razy do potęgi w
mianowniku. Normy euklidesowe do kwadratu redukują się i pozostaje nam dość proste
wyrażenie. W istocie, jeśli podstawimy nasz wzór na fi b, który działa dla każdego b, otrzymamy wzór na stan zredukowany
układu A wyrażony w terminach opisu gęstościowego stanu czystego, od którego zaczęliśmy, a mianowicie ket s bra s.
To jest więc nasz wzór na stan zredukowany układu A, zakładając, że złożony układ AB zaczął w
stanie czystym s. Możemy też używać tego wzoru bardziej ogólnie. W szczególności załóżmy,
że stan ab jest dany przez pewną macierz gęstości rho, która może mieć postać ket s bra s dla pewnego wektora stanu
kwantowego s, ale niekoniecznie. Wynika z tego zasadniczo przez liniowość, że stan zredukowany A jest
wyznaczany przez ten sam wzór co dla stanów czystych, z wyjątkiem tego, że podstawiamy jakąkolwiek macierz gęstości rho,
którą chcemy. Jako skrótowa notacja dość powszechne jest oznaczanie tego stanu zredukowanego przez jakąkolwiek nazwę używamy dla
macierzy gęstości rho w tym przypadku, ale umieszczamy indeks dolny wskazujący układ, na którym się skupiamy. Więc rho z dolnym
indeksem A oznacza stan zredukowany A, gdy złożony układ jest w stanie rho. Indeksy górne są też czasami używane
zamiast dolnych – to jest zasadniczo osobista preferencja i oznacza to samo
Skupialiśmy się na układzie A dla uproszczenia, ale możemy też uzyskać stan zredukowany układu B
analogicznie, gdzie wzór jest dostosowany w naturalny sposób. Wszystko jest symetryczne –
zasadniczo zamieniamy role A i B, a w szczególności suma przebiega tym razem po klasycznych stanach A,
a nie B. I w wzorze na ekranie zakładamy, że klasyczny zbiór stanów A nazywa się
Sigma. Wszystko to uogólnia się w dość prosty sposób na trzy lub więcej układów. Na przykład jeśli mamy trzy
układy A, B i C, które łącznie są w stanie opisanym przez macierz gęstości rho, to możemy uzyskać
stan zredukowany pary AB razem za pomocą wzoru pokazanego tutaj, jak również stan samego trzeciego układu
za pomocą drugiego wzoru. I możesz rozważyć inne kombinacje i uogólnić to na dowolną liczbę układów. Sumy są zawsze brane po
klasycznych zbiorach stanów układów, które są ignorowane, i wzorzec jest zawsze ten sam: macierz
gęstości, od której zaczynamy, jest zaklasyfikowana między iloczynem tensorowym macierzy jednostkowej a bras i kets odpowiadającymi stanom standardowej bazy.
Kończąc lekcję, powiem jeszcze trochę o definicjach, które właśnie omówiliśmy. Operacja na macierzach
gęstości, która opisuje stany zredukowane, ma nazwę i nazywa się śladem częściowym. Dla dwóch układów A i B
ślad częściowy po B i ślad częściowy po A są zdefiniowane tutaj na ekranie. Są to dokładnie te same
wzory, które widzieliśmy chwilę temu, i teraz myślimy o nich jako o funkcjach rho i nadajemy im
nazwy. Nazwy wyglądają jak ślad, z wyjątkiem tego, że jest indeks dolny, który mówi nam, który układ jest usuwany,
innymi słowy który układ to ten, po klasycznym zbiorze stanów którego sumujemy i który jest zaklasyfikowany między bra i
ket. Gdy bierzemy ślad częściowy naszego B na przykład, co opisuje pierwszy wzór, czasami mówimy, że
B jest „wyśledzony" (traced out), i analogicznie dla A. Intuicyjnie mówiąc, śledzenie układu
po prostu oznacza, że go odrzucamy lub po prostu ignorujemy. To jest jeden sposób na zdefiniowanie śladu
częściowego, a innym równoważnym sposobem jest powiedzenie, że te odwzorowania są unikalnymi liniowymi odwzorowaniami spełniającymi
wzory pokazane tutaj po prawej. Konkretnie, jeśli mamy iloczyn tensorowy dwóch macierzy M i N,
powiedzmy, i wykonujemy ślad częściowy po pierwszym układzie, to co otrzymujemy, to ślad pierwszej macierzy M razy
drugą macierz. A warunek jest symetryczny, gdy śledzimy po drugim układzie. Nie każda macierz, z której bralibyśmy
ślad częściowy, jest iloczynem tensorowym takim jak ten, ale każdą macierz można wyrazić jako kombinację liniową
iloczynów tensorowych i możemy określić ślad częściowy z tych warunków razem z faktem, że te odwzorowania są liniowe.
I dlatego to się nazywa śladem częściowym. Ta równoważna definicja może być
dość pomocna, bo często możemy jej używać zamiast pierwotnego wzoru. Oto przykład,
który to ilustruje. Załóżmy, że mamy parę qubit A i B w stanie, którego macierz gęstości jest tutaj pokazana na
ekranie. Jest to przykład stanu skorelowanego, gdzie A jest albo w stanie zero, albo w stanie jeden, każdy
z prawdopodobieństwem 1/2. Możemy więc myśleć o A jako o klasycznym. Jeśli A jest w stanie zero, to
B też, a jeśli A jest w stanie jeden, B jest w stanie plus. Jeśli chcemy wiedzieć, jaki jest stan zredukowany A,
śledzimy po B, a jeśli użyjemy drugiego wzoru z równoważnej definicji razem z liniowością, to możemy
obliczyć to dość łatwo. W szczególności ślad z ket 0 bra 0 wynosi jeden, podobnie jak ślad z ket plus bra
plus, więc te czynniki tensorowe znikają i pozostajemy ze stanem całkowicie mieszanym. Podobnie możemy obliczyć
stan zredukowany B, śledząc po A. Tym razem to pierwszy czynnik tensorowy jest tym, dla którego wykonujemy ślad, więc
używamy pierwszego wzoru z równoważnej definicji i pozostajemy z 1/2 razy ket 0 bra 0 plus 1/2 razy ket
plus bra plus, czyli innymi słowy tą samą macierzą gęstości, która pojawiła się kilka razy wcześniej. Uzyskałbyś dokładnie te
same wyniki, gdybyś użył wzorów z pierwszej definicji, ale jest to znacznie łatwiejszy sposób. To wszystko uogólnia się na trzy lub więcej
układów, ale w tym filmie zatrzymam się tutaj i zostawię to tobie do samodzielnego przemyślenia. I to jest koniec tej lekcji, która
wprowadziła macierze gęstości i opisała podstawy tego, jak działają. Omówiliśmy też sferę Blocha
a także różne typy korelacji i pojęcie stanu zredukowanego układu. Mam nadzieję, że dołączysz do mnie na
następną lekcję, która dotyczy kanałów – liniowych odwzorowań z macierzy gęstości na macierze gęstości, które
WEBVTT
opisują operacje na układach. Do zobaczenia
wkrótce.